If you are not familiar with object-oriented programming or its counterpart,
the functional programming paradigm, this may seem weird to you.
We called a few methods on an object.
The methods returned some values, but now, when we wanted to actually draw our
chart, we call the draw method on our original myChart variable.
What's happening behind the scenes, the, the dimple library actually implements
an object-oriented interface for its objects, in which the method calls on
the myChart object and you take the internal state of the object.
What does this mean?
Well, when you call the series and addAxis functions, they
actually add the axis and series objects into the chart that they're called on.
So now, when we call draw on myChart, myChart's been mutated by
the addSeries addAxis calls, such that they have all the data and
specification they need for the draw function to operate.
The fun thing about working in the debugger with Chrome is that as soon as we
call the draw function, the chart will immediately be drawn into the Web page.
Keep an eye on the Web page in the background here.
And even though we're pausing the debugger,
all the code we execute here has access to the Web page itself.
Calling the draw method,
we can see that a bar chart spontaneously appeared in our Web page window.
One last thing to note before we move on to better and
different charts, that the returned object from the draw function is
the chart object that we called it on.
If we inspect draw_chart, which we stored the return value of myChart.draw into,
we can see here that it's dimple.chart and
has all the same properties as our original chart.
And again, we can actually check whether it is equivalent to our initial chart
by using the triple equals operator in JavaScript and comparing it to myChart.
And we can see here that it is indeed the original chart.
This style of returning the object that you would call the method on is
exactly how D3 works and allows you to chain methods without having to go
through an intermediate representation or variable.